- This video is sponsored by Adam & Eve.
Used code "LEGAL" for 50% off one item
plus free shipping in the US and Canada.
Some exclusions apply.
- That means I'll expect you
to be at work and in
court as the She-Hulk.
- No, no, no.
Absolutely not. Not going to happen.
This is an employment
lawyer's worst nightmare.
(bright music)
Okay, today, we are looking at "She-Hulk."
Now I really want to like this show,
but so far, from the
little bit that I've seen,
my expectations about legal
realism are pretty low,
but, today, let's look at
the first half of Season 1 of "She-Hulk."
- The defendant used
their limitless resources,
political and monetary, for financial gain
at the expense of public safety,
causing the deaths of innocent people.
- [Speaker] Oh, that's so wordy.
- They did this because they believed
they would not be held accountable,
that their power shielded them
from very real consequences,
but, today, you, the jury,
can prove that's not the case.
- All right, off to a strong start.
We can see already that
Jen Walters has two degrees from UCLA,
one for undergrad and one for law school.
You know who else who has
two degrees from UCLA?
Your boy, LegalEagle.
Now, I can neither confirm nor or deny
that I also have incredible superpowers.
We'll find out later.
- I ask you to look only
at the facts of this case.
You'll see that my client
was well within his right
to protect his business interest.
These accidental deaths were
an unfortunate byproduct
of an ambitious expansion plan.
Did my client know lives
would be in danger?
That is debatable and depends
on your definition of knowing.
- Okay, so this is a
terrible closing argument.
It's basically just a word
salad of legal concepts
thrown together in a way that
is not persuasive at all,
and the craziest thing here
is that this is the defense,
which for some reason in
this alternate universe,
the defense gives their closing
argument in a criminal case
before the prosecution.
That is not how this works.
The prosecution has the burden of proof,
and they always go first in
terms of closing arguments.
So it makes absolutely
no sense that Jen Walters
has not given her closing
argument before the defense has,
but that's pretty far down
in terms of legal
inaccuracies at this point.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, so
this chick, pretty decent,
turned into a Hulk, like a chick Hulk.
- A She-Hulk?
- Exactly.
- [Speaker] She-Hulk, yeah!
- Okay, so I really enjoy
the supposed name of this
lawyer bar, the Legal Ease.
The thing is, though,
despite this being a trope
in lots of different TV
shows, in my experience,
lawyers don't congregate
in some nearby bar to the
courthouse after hours.
In my experience, lawyers
tend to drink alone at home.
It's actually kind of a problem.
Substance abuse is a
real thing among lawyers.
- We didn't win the case.
- Oh, yeah, we did.
- GLK & H had it declared a mistrial.
- Okay, so a mistrial was
declared. That's not crazy.
The standard for mistrial is that
the defendant cannot receive a fair trial.
The chances of receiving a fair trial
are irreparably damaged.
The thing is, though, when
a mistrial is declared,
there's gonna be a do-over.
They're going to have another trial.
You don't lose the case. The
defendant doesn't walk free.
It's just that this particular
jury has to be dismissed
and you have to do it all over again.
- Just the same.
Since you saved the lives
of the entire jury today,
GLK & H argued that the jury
was then biased in your favor.
- Well, what was I supposed to do?
Like, let them get hit
in the face with the desk
and then they have blunt force trauma
and they're all bleeding out
all over the courtroom floor?
- No, you did the right thing,
but it unraveled our case.
- It didn't unravel their
case, and, if anything,
it would be more reason
for her to be counsel
on the next trial,
because she's gotten
all this publicity that,
not only was she a lawyer,
but she also saved the lives of the jury,
so the idea that her district
attorney boss is upset
is preposterous.
- Jen, I'm sorry. I have to let you go.
Well, this makes you a
liability for the DA's office.
- What? Okay, all right.
Preposterous that they would be upset
that they lost the case
because of mistrial,
which isn't losing the case,
but double or triple so
that they're firing her
because she transformed into
She-Hulk and saved the jury.
There's an argument here
that this is a violation of the ADA.
The Americans with Disabilities
Act prohibits discrimination
against people with disabilities
in terms of employment,
and the Civil Rights Act of
1964 prohibits discrimination
on the basis of race, color,
religion, sex, or national origin,
and, here, she has a genetic abnormality
that makes her a superhero.
There are all kinds of issues here,
and, also, I mean, this is a small thing,
but, often, district
attorneys' offices have unions,
so there would be a whole
grievance procedure.
She's a government employee,
so she receives all kinds
of due process protections.
The manner in which she
was fired, impossible.
Absolutely impossible. Ridiculous.
It's just a plot device to
get her to go somewhere else.
(superhero transition music)
- Oh, hey, Devin.
Nando here. Just wanted
to clear something up.
That plot point makes way more sense
in the comic they're
taking it directly from.
There's a similar moment
where Jen is fired from her law firm
because, after she saves the jury,
the case Jen won is deemed a mistrial.
However, there are two
pretty big differences
that make the firing work in the book
better than it does in the show.
One, Jen is a mess.
She had a rough early 2000s,
but, second, more importantly,
because Jen was an Avenger at the time,
the court case in the
book is not interrupted by
Titania trying to mess up that courthouse,
but MODOK, the big evil
head in a floating chair
trying to freeze the entire planet.
So I think Jen's boss
has a stronger case here.
This is not an isolated incident.
Everyone on the planet has
been saved by She-Hulk,
so you could say Jen has undue leverage
over every potential juror in every case,
and therefore anyone arguing against Jen
could get a mistrial
on the basis that Jen
saved those jurors too.
(superhero transition music)
- I'd like to offer you a job.
Ms. Walters, you laid out
a winning case against us
before I had it declared
a mistrial, of course.
It's no easy feat against GLK & H,
so I would like you to come work for us.
- Okay, this is slightly less unrealistic,
and frankly I think this
probably would happen.
In the wake of Jen
Walters becoming She-Hulk
and saving the entire jury
and presumably having
above-average legal skills,
because she went to UCLA Law,
I can absolutely see that
some law firm would reach out
and want to capitalize
on that good publicity.
So, you know, I think that's a cool idea.
- You got me fired and
now you wanna hire me?
- To be head of a new division, yes.
Take some time to think-
- I accept,
but I will only do it
if I can hire my own
paralegal, non-negotiable.
- I truly do not care
who your paralegal is.
- Yes.
- Okay, that's a great line.
Would some senior partner care
about her hiring a paralegal?
Absolutely not whatsoever.
Kind of a ridiculous condition.
I would want to know how
much I was being paid.
I would want to know if I was
a capital or equity
partner in the law firm.
I would want to know if I get
a percentage of the law firm's
revenue, because, you know,
unclear how much actual lawyering
she's going to be able to do,
so if they want to
capitalize on her notoriety,
and there are lots of
partners in law firms
that don't actually do much practicing.
They are there to be rainmakers
and get people to come in the door.
You know, she should get a percentage of
the profits of that law firm.
She has negotiated none of these things.
You would expect her to do so.
I am questioning her business skills,
if not her legal skills at this point.
- We just started a superhuman
law division and I want you,
well, the She-Hulk, to be the face of it.
- Oh.
- Yeah, okay, so in a world
where superheroes are real,
I can absolutely see law firms
specializing in superhero law.
You know, this particular
YouTube channel has covered
a lot of the implications
of superheroes being,
shall we say, legally controversial,
and I can absolutely believe that
there would be a million different things
that not only superheroes
would need to have covered
from a legal perspective,
but also, you know,
victims of superhero crime
or supervillain crime
and the aftermath of
superheroes saving the day,
but also causing lots and lots of damage.
So, yeah, I think a superhero law division
is a really neat idea.
A little upset that
they didn't call me
first about that though.
- That means I'll expect you to be at work
and in court as the She-Hulk.
- Right now?
- [Holden] Mhm.
- Um.
- [Holden] Go ahead.
- No, no, no, absolutely not.
Not going to happen.
This is an employment
lawyer's worst nightmare
that some partner at the firm,
some old white guy is demanding that
Jen Walters turn into She-Hulk
as a condition of her employment.
Absolutely not.
You know, there are places
that can require you
to dress in a certain way.
Hooters is the classic example,
that there is a sexual
nature to the restaurant,
and so they have been allowed to require
certain sexualized uniforms
and things of that nature.
- Read the sign, pervert.
- [Homer] D'oh!
- A law firm doesn't have that purpose,
and you can't have differing requirements
between men and women
or a specific person.
That's crazy, especially given
the Rule 34 nature of She-Hulk in general.
Do not Google that.
Yeah, I mean, this is not going to fly.
Now, arguably, the law firm would say,
"Well, we hired you
because you have notoriety as She-Hulk
and we want She-Hulk to be the lawyer."
The thing is everybody knows that
her identity of Jen Walters
is synonymous with She-Hulk,
so I don't think they
have a good argument.
- Mr. Blonsky, I was expecting-
- The Abomination, right?
You won't be seeing much of him about.
Honestly, I've completely
transformed myself.
You know, physically,
obviously, but also spiritually.
- Okay, I think this is a really neat idea
in the world of superhero law.
You have a former
supervillain who was captured,
put in jail, in a supermax
jail, and served out his time.
Now, query whether he actually
would get out of jail,
given that I think a lot of his charges,
it's been a long time
since I've seen the original "Hulk" movie,
involve a lot of attempted murder.
So, you know, query whether
he's actually eligible for parole,
but the thing is, prisons,
theoretically at least,
are not in the habit of
confining people for
the rest of their lives
unless the crime itself calls
for them to be incarcerated
for their entire lives, and
it's entirely possible that,
if all of the charges were
related to property damage,
then, okay, he served his time,
and he might be eligible for parole,
and you can imagine, in
a world of supervillainy,
that people would be uneasy about
a supervillain being released
back into the rest of
humanity, but the thing is that
the prison shouldn't be
confining him forever,
and this is a really interesting
analogy to real life.
We have people that did something bad,
but the punishment doesn't allow them
to be confined for the
rest of their lives,
and they have to be
reintegrated eventually.
So this is a really cool idea.
I like that they're exploring this.
- So far, there have
been no statements made
by Emil Blonsky's attorney
after shocking footage leaked,
showing the Abomination participating in
what appears to be an
underground fight club
after having somehow escaped from prison.
Oh.
Do you understand that this
constitutes another crime
and totally destroys
your chances at parole?
- What?
- Okay, so that's accurate.
If a prison inmate
decided to leave prison,
that would be considered a separate crime,
though you would have to
criminally prosecute them
for that separate crime.
It wouldn't just be up
to the prison to say,
you escaped from prison
and we're tacking on, you know,
10 years to your sentence.
- I was forced to leave my cell,
but I returned of my own free will.
- Who forced you to escape.
- Sorcerer Supreme of the
Mystic Arts, and his name is-
- Wong. Just Wong.
- Okay, so I think what's
gonna happen here is that
this is going to involve
the parole aspect of it.
You would imagine that
someone trying to get
out of jail, to escape,
would reflect negatively
on a parole board hearing.
- What?
- And, here, Emil Blonsky is
going to try to ameliorate that
by saying that he didn't try to escape.
He was forced to escape by Wong.
- We do have a witness who
is able to clear Mr. Blonsky
of any wrongdoing on his part.
- Then we'll start with that then.
- Well, yes, the witness is
prepared to give a statement.
- Okay, that is completely ridiculous
that the stakes here are,
will Wong show up to this
parole board hearing?
I mean, I imagine what you would do is
you would probably want to
have him testify in person,
but for belts and suspenders,
you would get a written
declaration from Wong.
Jennifer Walters would write it up
and Wong would sign it
under penalty of perjury
and you would provide
that to the prison board
so that nothing can go wrong,
to make sure that the
witness is testifying
that he forced Blonsky
to escape from prison.
This whole thing about Wong,
will he show up or not,
is totally contrived.
(magic whirring)
(dramatic music)
(audience applauds)
- Here is a cease and desist.
- Cease and desist?
What cease and desist?
- Okay, so I'm not sure on what basis
they can issue a cease and desist
to stop Donny Blaze from
using this particular magic.
I mean, look, that has
never stopped a lawyer
from writing a cease and desist letter.
We see on the internet all
sorts of terrible lawyers
write cease and desist letters.
- However, "Dilly Dilly"
is the motto of our realm.
- So, I guess, in this sense,
this is just like real life.
You have very dubious circumstances
in which to force someone
to stop doing something
that you don't want them to
do, and yet the lawyer is
writing a cease and desist
letter to threaten them.
- We have filed a complaint
and a motion for preliminary injunction
against the defendant,
citing unfair competition
and gross negligence.
- I must say, counselor,
I am hard pressed to believe that
a magic trick could
constitute gross negligence.
- Well, okay, yeah,
there is the question of
whether a magic trick can
constitute gross negligence,
but the bigger issue here is that
Wong doesn't have standing to file suit
on the basis of negligence.
Negligence is a cause of action
that requires you to be injured
by the act of negligence.
So, you know, the young
woman who was sent to,
you know, the demon realm,
she has a cause of action
for gross negligence.
Wong does not. He's a
complete third party.
Now, with respect to
unfair competition, here,
Wong is not engaged in commerce.
He's not competing with Donny Blaze,
so that doesn't work either.
Also, you would probably
just turn this over
to the district's attorney.
You have someone walking around,
using what is effectively a deadly weapon,
engaged in all kinds of nefarious acts.
That's probably something
the district's attorney
should probably prosecute here.
- Do you have any witnesses
who can corroborate your claim?
- Yes, we do, your honor.
(dramatic music)
- [Speaker] I'm gonna show you all
my high school dance routine right now.
- By the way, lack of evidence
is not the problem here.
You can have tons and tons of evidence,
but if you don't have a cause of action
that works in the circumstances,
this case should be dismissed,
and, here, this is
exactly the kind of case
that should be dismissed
on a motion to dismiss.
- I move to dismiss. You
cannot copyright magic.
- No.
- There is precedent.
- According to Jen Walters,
they're not filing a copyright suit,
because you can't copyright magic.
It's, ugh!
It's, ugh.
It's like someone pulled
out a legal dictionary,
flipped to a random page, threw
some words into the script,
and then, you know, set it in a courtroom.
- My client is obviously
novating this ridiculous
defalcation.
This is just a blatant attempt at
"nemo debet bis vexari
pro una et eadem causa."
No further questions, your honor.
- Hello, fellas.
- Good evening, my lady.
- Before I send my little friend here
back to his own dimension,
I was wondering if you would agree to
the terms of our cease and desist.
- Eh, maybe.
- Absolutely.
(beast snarls)
- Fine, okay, we agree!
- My office will be in touch.
- Yeah, okay.
So, I mean, forming a contract
while threatening someone with a demon,
probably going to constitute duress,
and whatever terms they have
agreed to is not going to work.
Basically, this is the
Scoleri Brothers joke
from "Ghostbusters II."
- All right, I rescind the order!
Case dismissed!
- Hooray, we won the case!
- Now do something!
- I've got a special delivery
for a one Jennifer Walters.
- I recognize a process
server when I see one.
- Ha, right.
I've got court documents filed
by Titania Worldwide LLC.
- Okay, I have to say I really like
this joke going in the
other direction and saying,
"Oh, yeah, I totally recognize
you're a process server.
Just give me the papers."
So often we hear about people
trying to dodge service.
There's no point. You're
going to be served eventually.
It's just driving up court costs.
- She's suing you for
misuse of a trademark.
- What trademark?
She's suing me over the name
She-Hulk? But that's my name.
- Not if she trademarked it first, right?
- Oh, is that how it works, your honor?
- Yeah.
- Get out of here.
- Hold on, sorry. Thank you.
- Spoiler, that is not
exactly how a trademark works.
Hopefully, we'll talk about that more.
- I'm so sorry, little child,
but the line starts way back there.
_ I don't wanna cut.
- Okay, so this is Titania,
who is the supervillain
that burst into the
courtroom in Episode 1,
and nearly killed half of the jury
by throwing a table at them.
Why is she not in jail?
She engaged in
a whole bunch of accounts
of attempted murder.
- What seems to be the issue?
- You're using my name to
sell your trashy products,
and you're suing me?
- Get over it, Jennifer.
The name She-Hulk is mine.
- So, Titania here is
using the mark She-Hulk
in commerce with a bunch
of makeup products,
some of which appear to
have dubious efficacy,
so that makes sense.
To get a trademark, you
have to, generally speaking,
use that mark in commerce,
which I think tees up a
really interesting idea
in the world of superhero law,
because you have all these superheroes
who are using a name,
but they're not really
using it in commerce.
They're using it to save people.
You can imagine, Superman,
he would never try to
commercially capitalize
on the term Superman,
whereas you can imagine a
whole bunch of other people
would want to capitalize on that.
So you can have a situation
where someone is using a name,
here, She-Hulk, in an altruistic way,
but someone else is
gonna be first to market
with some product in commerce,
and you can only get a trademark
if you're using something in commerce.
- You said you didn't like
the name She-Hulk anyways.
- I don't!
- Okay.
- It is just what people
have decided to call me.
It's not who I am.
- Okay, so this adds a
really interesting wrinkle,
because trademark is not
the end of this discussion.
Often, people have publicity
rights in their name
if you have a certain amount of notoriety.
People like Beyonce and
Donald Trump have trademarked
and also created other
protections in their own name
to protect it from
being diluted or tarnished
by someone else's use,
even as a trademark.
- GLK & H made She-Hulk
the face of our superhuman law division,
and now we find ourselves
in the middle of a frivolous lawsuit.
No one hires a firm that
can't handle its own messes.
- I am going to fix this, sir.
(Holden chuckles)
- No, you won't.
- Okay, this is great.
This absolutely would happen.
If you had a partner in a major law firm
who was being sued in a frivolous fashion,
it is absolutely the case that
the other members of the firm
would just unleash hell on the party
that was engaging in
the frivolous lawsuit.
So, it's really funny that the
senior partner is kinda like,
it's a bad look for us to be sued
and to lose this kind of thing,
so we're gonna make sure that you win.
- Since the first public appearance
of Jennifer Walters in her Hulk form,
the public has unanimously identified her
with the name She-Hulk.
In fact, the name She-Hulk
had not even been recorded
in public discourse
until that debut.
- Okay, by the way, maybe a small thing,
but I know TV shows portray
the practice of law as
basically just two lawyers at
a table arguing with a judge.
That's not how a summary
judgment motion works.
A summary judgment motion, number one,
has to be noticed 75 days ahead of time.
In California, you have to
write a separate statement.
So you have to compile
every single relevant fact,
put it into an Excel spreadsheet,
and show how there are no
issues of material fact
that are in dispute,
and then you have to have 30 pages of law
explaining why you're entitled
to win as a matter of law.
It's such a paper-intensive thing.
It would be hundreds
and hundreds of pages,
though I can see why a TV show
would not want to portray a
real motion for summary judgment
because it's super, super boring.
- The defendant is exploiting goodwill
towards my client and
her better-known cousin
in order to sell her
non-FDA-approved sham products.
We ask the court to grant our
motion for summary judgment
and order our requested remedies.
- That makes no sense.
They should have gone in for
a temporary restraining order,
a TRO, and eventually a
preliminary injunction, a PI,
because when you're dealing
with these kinds of IP rights,
this is where you get irreparable harm,
which is what is required for a TRO
to restrain someone temporarily.
You have to show irreparable harm,
and when you're dealing with
these kinds of IP rights,
they're really tarnishing the name,
and it's really hard, if not
impossible, to get that back.
They're tarnishing the name She-Hulk
by associating it with
shoddy beauty products.
That would absolutely be the sort of thing
that would be stopped pending
a resolution in this case.
- Okay, first of all, sham?
- Why is the client talking?
Assuming this is an oral argument,
the lawyer is the only one
who can talk, not the client.
Sit down and shut up.
That's no.
- She-Hulk was not. You can sit down.
What my client is trying to say is that
Jennifer Walters was not
interested in the She-Hulk name
until it became associated with
this incredibly successful
line of products.
If we may.
(crowd chattering)
- I will not answer to that name.
You know why? Because it's not my name.
- Yeah, okay, so that's a good argument
that this is a bonafide use in commerce.
She is not using it in commerce,
and therefore the the
trademark is successful.
Now, a couple things here.
There's a difference
between creating a trademark
and registering a trademark.
To register a trademark,
you have to go to the
USPTO to register it.
Usually, that takes a couple of years,
assuming that there aren't any objections,
and then it is registered with
the United States government
and then you can file suit.
Generally speaking,
you have to register it
to be able to file suit,
but that's not how you create a trademark.
You create a trademark
by using it in commerce,
and just because it's not registered
doesn't mean you don't have the trademark,
so there's an issue here as to,
who was the first to use
the mark in commerce?
That's who's going to win,
not the person who was
able to register it first.
- Because I made a dating
profile as She-Hulk,
and when on several dates as She-Hulk,
showing a clear pattern of using the name.
Every single one of those dates
is a corroborating witness.
This is how I win this case.
- I specifically remember her
referring to herself as She-Hulk.
- Okay, so I understand
this as a plot device.
It's fun that they're gonna
call in all the ex-boyfriends,
and, you know, show that
she actually went by She-Hulk.
The thing is that is not
probative of the issue here.
She has to show use in commerce.
Showing that you used the mark
She-Hulk in a dating profile
is not using that in commerce.
That's not going to help them,
so all of these witnesses
are completely irrelevant.
They should object and never
be let into the courtroom.
Now, that being said,
the best argument that she
could make here is that
she was hired on the
basis of being She-Hulk.
- And I want you, well, the
She-Hulk, to be the face of it.
- She has held herself out
as She-Hulk the lawyer,
so the evidence that
they should use here is
calling her clients to the stand,
showing that they hired her
on the basis of the fact
that she was She-Hulk
and she was portraying
herself as She-Hulk.
- Motion for summary judgment is granted.
Titania and her subsidiaries will cease
usage of the She-Hulk name,
effective immediately.
- It makes sense that
Jennifer Walters wins.
I wish they would've
dealt with the issue of
a truly altruistic superhero though.
Superman, Spider-Man,
Captain America, you know,
they're not going to be using
their particular marks or
their names in commerce,
so it would've been more fun
to deal with that particular issue.
(superhero transition music)
- Oh, man, then you've gotta
read "Ultimate Spider-Man."
They did a thing where
Kingpin bought the wrestling company
where Peter Parker debuted as Spider-Man,
so Kingpin now owns the rights
to the Spider-Man trademark
and uses it to sell
all of the licensed
Spider-Man merchandise.
It's pretty genius, although
I guess it only really works
if your hero has a secret identity
and cannot claim the trademark themselves.
(superhero transition music)
- Okay, that was the first
five episodes of "She-Hulk."
Now it's time to give it
a grade for legal realism.
(lively music)
Man, I wanted to like it.
There's some funny jokes,
if for no other reason than the line-
- Captain America!
- They did cover some legal issues
that exclusively would've
come up in a superhero world
and dealt with them in a
way that is quasi-realistic.
That being said, the courtroom
scenes are complete nonsense.
All of the legal terminology
is just complete word salad,
so, sadly, I'm gonna
have to give "She-Hulk"
a C for legal realism.
Legal inaccuracies make Devin mad.
Yeah, so the bottom line here is that
some of these clients got royally
screwed by their attorney.
If that sounds pleasurable to you,
then check out today's sponsor, wink,
and check out this link over
here for more LegalEagle.
So, click on this link,
or I'll see you in court.